ein etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zur video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich denke mal die meisten
von euch können sich alles wieder
erinnern wo ich diese loks cargo iphones
erstellt habe und heute wird es glaube
ich wirklich dass ich habe die seite
wies dort noch weiter im auge behalten
und kurz vorweg bei beeskow werden ganz
viele waren verstärkt die nicht
zustellbar waren mit denen irgendwas
passiert ist irgendwo verloren gegangen
sind kein teil alles mögliche von
gamestop amazon und noch ein paar andere
companies verkaufen da halt dann bewarb
und du kannst sie ersteigern und da war
vor einiger zeit ein angebot da wurden
202 damen taschen versteigert die sollen
insgesamt einen wert haben von über
25.000 euro und vp was extrem viel ist
und ich hab dir ersteigert wir sind zum
glück jetzt angekommen und wir schauen
heute mal ob ich da einen guten hier
gemacht habe oder halt vielleicht auch
nicht keine ahnung die ganze aktion auf
einem anderen kanal mitgefilmt deswegen
es gibt mir da mal im hin und barcodes
ausschütte hier die highlights frauen
taschen und portemonnaies
202 stück 202 stück überlege gar nicht
einfach mal dem
abschicken das letzte womit ich mich
auskenne sind frauen taschen aber egal
es ist jetzt einfach mal eine challenge
ich habe gewonnen
1100 euro heute was geht meine taschen
sind gerade angekommen hinter mir fährt
und lkw nicht langweilig den coachee
respektieren muss diese leute lkws damit
palette
[Musik]
hey leute jetzt heißt es wieder hoch
tragen 111 kilo muss los so sieht die
übrigens gerade aus also ich muss das
jetzt weil logischerweise auf machen
damit ich das einzelne fragen kann
zumindest oder was heißt einzeln aber
ist halt echt schwer dann bauen wir mal
oder 111 kilo
du scheinst du kannst es sind ja
umbringen
[Musik]
naja
ich habe es geschafft wirklich
einrichten gut durchtrainiert aber
morgen 111 kilo in hohen ersten stock
stören ist richtige herausforderung ich
schwitze ist ungefähr eine dreiviertel
stunde gedauert und jetzt reicht's ich
halte es ist alles oben
also eigentlich habe ich die 200 zwei
damen passend für 28 euro stärke ich war
auch der einzige bieter ob das jetzt ein
gutes zeichen das weiß ich nicht
eigentlich eher dicht aber dann kommen
noch gewöhnen so ihr kennt schon immer
haben wir die zehn prozent wie stop
gebühr in diesem fall dann 82 euro plus
noch 180 euro bearbeitungsgebühren und
noch einmal versandkosten von 860 euro
kanal insgesamt habe ich also bezahlt
1270 euro das ist schon eine menge ich
bin echt mal gespannt ob ich die 1270
euro wieder reinbekommen wenn ich die
tasten weiterverkaufen aber ich bin
eigentlich guter dinge und wie ihr geld
sparen könnt das erfahrt ihr jetzt von
mir der heutige sponsor des videos ist
nämlich alle finden und das checken
jetzt mal kurz aus wer kann es
eigentlich nicht ich glaube nur die
wenigsten leute dass man sich denkt okay
ich habe mein ganzes leben schon alles
direkt bezahlt auch ich musste damals
als ich mit youtube angefangen habe habe
ich meine neue kamera gezogen ja dieser
halt erstmal auf raten abbezahlen und
ratenzahlungen werden oft mit zehn
prozent verzinst
das ist schon eine menge und da kommt
jetzt endlich findet spielende finden
kann ihn nämlich helfen zinsen zu sparen
und dich schneller schuldenfrei zu
machen ganz wichtig eine finne ist
natürlich kostenlos ihr könnt euch die
app im place toro runterladen und dort
und erstmal ein paar persönliche daten
hinterlegen zumindest die die elfen
braucht dann könnt ihr so wie ich es
euch jetzt hier einwände einfach ein
foto von eurem letzten ratenkauf machen
und den bei nfn hochladen any finden
prüft das ganze und schaut ob sie euch
ein besseres angebot machen können dann
bekommt ihr natürlich von anif in
bescheid ein ratenkauf wird dann direkt
abbezahlt und du kannst deine schulden
auf jeden fall flexibler und schneller
los werden also einfacher geld sparen
ist glaube ich nur schwierig möglich und
das coole ist mit alex wie 20 bekommt
ihr noch mal 20 euro abzukaufen ersten
ratenkauf den hierbei eine von hochladen
deswegen check das game ab erster link
in der video beschreibung und wir machen
weiter mit dem video vielleicht was geht
vor mir befinden sich jetzt gerade
wirklich 202 damen passen bzw
140 damen taschen und 60 portemonnaies
ich glaube es sind aber auch modernen
portemonnaies wobei an sich
portemonnaies kann ja auch jeder also
jetzt zum beispiel sondern was ich jetzt
sehr das würde mir auch gut stehen würde
ich einfach mal schätzen oder hast du
hinter der kamera habe ich jetzt johanna
die war auch dabei als ich ankam und hat
ein bisschen geholfen die zu sortieren
man muss auch sagen hast du echt super
gemacht weil oben sind ja die ganzen
wertvollen sachen ne und unten die wir
halt trotz sind aber ich habe es noch
nicht gesehen also zumindest nicht so
wirklich und wir machen das jetzt ganz
in ruhe sacken das alles mal aus und
schauen dann auch was den körper kommen
einzig wird nichts
hier sind wirklich vor ein paar tagen
ich habe das ja auch alles mit gefilmt
aber 111 kilo angekommen damit hat sie
glaube so viele damen taschen gehe ich
hatte niemanden deutschland oder
nicht mal da gb oder wie es google
verlässt vorbei die haben wahrscheinlich
teurer sagt dann würde ich sagen fangen
wir mal mit an ein koffer oder keine
ahnung das ist ja keine damen taste da
steht ja nicht meine marke dran da
nichts besonderes wenn man glück hat
christ vielleicht auf dem flohmarkt
dafür noch 15 euro es hat mir leute hier
das ist noch in einem sehr guten zustand
von converse mail entscheider hier steht
sogar noch einen drauf 460 euro vom 19
das tut einem schon macht die rund
20.000 das ist schon echt heftiger scan
glaube ich der da steht das kann ich mir
am besten wenn nicht forschen aber wir
haben ja noch 200 exemplare guck mal
hier das ist hier ich dachte erst dass
westerwelle das aber ist nicht so was
ist deine gäste erst seit 1981 gibt es
dass leute weil ich nicht mehr gäste
wo ist die kaputt
ist kaputt
dadurch dass der henkel kaputt ist hat
die taschen leichtes problem alter aber
sonst würde ich mal schätzen 50 euro
oder sogar mehr den rucksack von
hörschel ich habe genau den gleichen
look sagt anderes muster und mein
rucksack hat 90 euro gekostet das ist
genau der gleiche der ist zwar schon
gebraucht aber ich gehe mal davon aus
dass man hierfür sicherlich vielleicht
auch noch jetzt euro bekommt meint
wieder sind auch so richtige die seine
taschen drin also habe ich jetzt auf den
fotos nicht gesehen aber ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass da auch taschen
drin sind die so 300 euro kosten oder ja
ich weiß nicht in welcher es bleibt
spannend das hier ist von guck mal 180
euro direkt aufs tor halt raus die marke
ist so eine designertasche aus italien
latin modell impression 100 prozent made
in italy weiter geht's das ist super
entspannt und da bin ich mir sicher das
hat auch ein werk das ist zwar klein und
fein aber wertig porsche design karten
etui schaut mal hier das kostet doch
bestimmt 50 euro oder ja hier mit seinem
kleinen dingen also wenn ich 40
portemonnaie ist vom porsche design
dabei haben das ist leider schon 2000
euro wieder drin also jetzt halt noch
mal fest ich habe jetzt acht tage
ausgepackt portemonnaie das hat schon
alles zusammen bestimmten gesamtwert da
was da liegt von über 300 euro geschätzt
weiter geht es in der reklamation vom
datum 24 erster 2020 steht er sogar
drauf darum wo das reklamiert das muss
ich jetzt herausfinden und frauen
unterhose guck mal
presseleute die tasche ist von kojima 80
oder 100 euro sollte den kommunen
gemacht ich muss das ja auch eingepackt
lassen als nächstes haben wir hier in
der boutique eine umhängetasche für die
coolen einstein oder die kanaren rocken
oder nicht johanna sagt 50 oder 60
jahren war den nächsten rucksack der ist
aber in einem ganz schlechten zustand
war ist da noch irgendwas drin richter
schon richtig gebraucht nichts
besonderes schaut mal hier o mein gott
hier leute aha libeskind diese tasche
die wir absolut was für meine mama leute
gebt euch mal diese tasche hier und ich
bin mir sicher libeskind ist eine teure
marke hier steht da vielleicht doch ein
preis 399 euro 90 und die ist wirklich
einem top-zustand du weißt was mir
aufgefallen ist es vorne schrott leider
kann man all das kann ja nicht sein dann
kriegt man ja direkt für weniger dafür
okay leute nicht im kopf den sand
stecken weiter geht's hier haben wir zum
beispiel ein etui das hatte ich gerade
auch schon einmal hier von einem winkel
von rll auch leider der reißverschluss
hier ein bisschen brocken aber guter
dinge dass man das wieder fixen kann
hier haben wir zum beispiel als nächstes
lauf moss kino einen frauen portemonnaie
problem ist nur hier fehlt das n die
nächste tasche die ist von friede tasche
von sarah kern glaube sogar die habe ich
hier einmal und irgendwo habe ich ja
noch ein zweites mal gesehen hier haben
wir die nächste sarah kern tasche drin
schöne tasche muss ich dann tauschte mit
laser cut article id farbe schwarz die
kleine kostet 60 okay würde ich schon
auf 100 euro schätzen dann läuft das
team langsam also ich glaube dass der
wert der da jetzt liegt müsste auf jeden
fall mittlerweile 5 600 euro sein ach
guck mal hier die nächste sache kern
tasche so nämlich da drin ist einfach
noch eine sarah kern tasche die kann man
drinnen fest wäre siehst du das ist hier
noch in einem richtig guten zustand und
ich glaube dass hier kostet auch das
tape juni nein wie viel denn wirklich
beides zusammen 40 als wenn die leute
schaut mal dass die doch eigentlich ganz
schön aus die hab ich doch schon einmal
oder 180 plus 180 diesmal richtig schön
hier auch noch so original eingepackt
wird papier drin relativ gut gestimmt
heißt wenn ich das verkaufen sollte ich
das alles zumindest 1200 euro wieder
raus habe hier haben wir die nächste
sarah kern tasche auch wieder 60 so 60
zack für die alban muttis hier manchmal
meine mama hat auch so eine zum
einkaufen standardmäßige equipment in
jedem vw deutsche muttis mit rum fahren
da ist das hinten im kopf herum ich
würde jedem 850 euro drauf wetten dass
du das in jedem deutschen autorin im
kopf herum führen dass hier in tommy
hilfiger rucksack ist weil es nicht so
ein gutes tust obwohl doch der zustand
ist stabil aber irgendwie weißen
rucksack ach guck mal hier ist der osten
in höheren kundenreklamationen vom 30 17
20 21 uhr zurückgegeben würde ich auch
mal sagen 30 euro was haben wir denn
noch gutes hier haben wir eine tasche
die heißt aber eigentlich auch nicht
verkehrt die s auch noch neu verpackt
kostet hier noch 67 eur 99 runtergesetzt
von ursprünglich x
179 euro zu und dann haben wir hier die
nächste taxi macht eigentlich ein guten
eindruck und hier ist auch wieder eine
gutschrift drin 1 70 eur 99 war henkel
gerissen
naja hier ist der karabinerhaken
gerissen trotzdem schade schade schade
nein wir können auch neun holen bei mir
geht es darum die großen deals bin ja
kein reparaturservice gras ok weiter
geht es mit der nächsten tranche die ist
von us polo sls sn hier scheint alles
dran zu sein weil der reißverschluss
kaputt ich heiße nein der ist nicht mal
mehr dran hier ist nicht nur mehr
sorry an die nachbarn entschuldigung
aber noch ein original eingepackt ist
portemonnaie von libeskind das wäre auch
was für meine mama hat übrigens weiter
geburtstag dann denke hier das einfach
und tun so als hätte ich selber mir was
gedacht fabrizio ja so ein coup
es ist einfach das ist das zeichen vom
passagier aus ibiza eigentlichkeit für
den urlaub warum einzel nicht mehr guck
macht jedoch und dann ist noch mit
tranche zusätzlich drin monaco blue also
diese hier würde ich auch bei mindestens
hundert wenn nicht sogar 200 euro
einstufen die hat echte gute qualität
ich suche jetzt wirklich nur noch die
teuren sachen raus das hier ist
irgendwie so ein portemonnaie von ist
eine clutch tschuldigung und dann habe
ich hier sogar noch mal eine klatsche
gefunden an denen das ist ein
portemonnaie das ist ein portmonee von
deluxe und das hier ist eine tasche die
nächste tasche das ist so eine richtige
mein geschichtslehrer tasche ist dass so
junge hippe geschichtslehrer die kommen
mit seiner tasche die mein
geschichtslehrer damals schöne grüße an
herrn carsten pump impfung
vor leute das klingt gut hier haben war
porsche design tasche die farbe gefällt
mir zwar nicht so das ist teuer hey
leute jetzt bin ich gespannt ich tippe
das ist der absolute jackpot wenn man
glück haben konzentriert hat sie über
300 euro porsche-titel bittet ihr schaut
euch diese wunderbare kassen da machen
wir mal im schnelldurchlauf weiter die
haben war eine geldbörse rein hier ist
die nächste sarah kern tasche wenn ich
mal wieder hier ist hierzu euro tippen
oder so wenn überhaupt 60 sogar hier
einmal annika weiter geht's mit je mehr
in new york war ich sie herzlich auf
kulturbeutel basis angelehnt die nächste
kulturbeutel tasche und hier aha
roger nochmal tamaris dann haben wir
hier noch so ein paar portemonnaies team
erst ins auge stechen von wie ist das
noch mal weißt du sie dann lieber
hiervon sollte würde ich schon auch so
dass die portemonnaies wert haben so
leute so sieht das aus wir haben hier
wirklich noch taschen über taschen dies
auch defekt da hier mal ein ordner
geordnete krank mein gott ist das
hässlich also hier ist jetzt wirklich
unterm strich leider nur noch schrott
drin also die guten sachen habe ich alle
raus klick ich würde aber schon sagen
dass da ist ein wert liegen kann von war
schon eigentlich über 1500 euro ich
denke dass alles gleich mal zusammen und
sage euch das schon mal aber es wird
trotzdem und was war schwer sein diese
1000 zwar wieder rein zu bekommen wenn
ich das halt alles verkaufen sollte ich
tue davon so ein paar sachen auf dieses
winters verlinkt ich euch in der
wiederbestellung also wenn da irgendwas
weißt du ich hätte ja gerne mal
reinschauen welche preise nehmen die
dann für diese 24.000 euro wieder einen
titel stehen das ist doch einfach nur
frech also sorry aber da habe ich mir
wirklich mehr ausgemacht ich habe
gedacht ich hab da diese meines lebens
gemacht und wird auf jeden fall mit den
taschen mindestens 5000 euro wieder
verdienen aber die sind halt zum großen
teil einfach schrott letzt sind die alle
komplett neue wäre natürlich dafür ja
nicht mal ansatzweise 3000 euro bekommen
ich weiß nicht wie die 24.000 com na ja
leute wir sind uns gleich auf jeden fall
noch mal wieder so leute was geht ja was
soll ich sagen ich hab das ganze ist ein
bisschen geordnet videos doch fertig
geschnitten ich muss sagen im erst sein
bin ich schon sehr enttäuscht also
zumindest sehr überrascht also ich bin
jetzt nicht mega enttäuscht ich meinen
plan 1100 euro sind viel geld aber ich
finds krass wie die einfach auf fast 25
kate habe ich mein wo also selbst wenn
ich jede tasche neu google komme ich
vielleicht auch weil ihr 1000 ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube dass ich
nicht mal die 1200 euro die investiert
haben wieder raus bekomme ich denke
vielleicht soja 8 900 wenn es gut läuft
vielleicht 1000 aber mehr wird das auf
keinen fall na ja echt schade aber so
kann man heute fällen ich hoffe trotzdem
dass video hat euch gefallen der wille
war da ja kann man nichts machen leute
wir sind fast wieder eine million
abonniert sehr gerne für weitere solche
projekte und wir sehen uns die tage
wieder gibt's neues video drei leute und
hier seht ihr noch mal 111 kilogramm
taschen von denen die hälfte kaputt ist